الفونيتو هو الاتحاد الاوروبي ضاعان اليد
في اليد لمواجهه اي تهديد خارجيه من خلال
توقيع اتفاقيه للتعاون والتنسيق اتفاقيه
تحمل رسائل مباشره الى موسكو عن عزم
الطرفين مواصله لدعم اوكرانيا في حربها
امام روسيا في تفاصيل الاتفاقيه خمسه
محاور اساسيه اولها ضروره انخراط الحلف في
الدفاع عن جميع الخلفاء بالاضافه الى
تعزيز الدفاعات الاوروبيه ثانيها تولي
الحلف مهام الحفاظ على الامن عبر المحيط
الاطلسي ثالث الجنود اتفاق الجانبين على
نقل الشراكه بينهما الى مستويات الاعلى
رابع هذا تعهد الجانبين لعب دور المتكامل
في دعم السلام الدولي وخامتها وقد يكون
الاهم في الوقت الراهن هو تعزيز النيته
لدعم اوكرانيا في الحرب المتواصله مع
روسيا
لقد وقعنا للتو لاعلان المشتركه الثالثه
لحلف الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي لتطوير
الشراكه بيننا منذ قرابه العام وساعات بعد
اجتياح روسيا لاوكرانيا في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير التقينا هنا في مقر
الناتو الرئيس بوتل اراد ان يسيطر على
اوكرانيا في ايام قليله واراد ان يقسمنا
ولقد فشل في الامرين معا وبشكل واضح القوه
الروسيه تم دحرها من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه
النظام في موسكو يريد اوروبا مختلفه يريد
السيطره على جيرانه وهو يرى الحريه
والديمقراطيه كتهديد الله وسيكون لهذا اثر
البعيد ولهذا يجب ان نستمر في تقويه
الروابط بين اعضاء ويجب ان نستمر في تقويه
الشراكه بين الميت والاتحاد الاوروبي ويجب
نزيد دعمنا لاوكرانيا
مواصله دعم اوكرانيا في الحرب مع روسيا لم
يمر دون اثاره في حفظه موسكو حيث تعتبر
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاي باتروشف
ان الصراع في اوكرانيا يتحول لمواجهه بين
روسيا والنيتو مؤكدا ان الغربه يسعى الى
تقطيع اوصى لروسيا
وفي مواجهه التعاون المشاركه بين مختلف
الحلفاء الغربيين تتجه موسكو الى تطوير
اسلحتها سينما النوويه منها وهو ما اكلها
وزير الدفاع روسي سرجو الذي قال ان موسكو
ستواصل تطوير الثالوث النووي كضامن
لسيادتها وسلامتها كما اعلن شيبوه ان قوه
المسلحه الروسيه ستقوم بتطوير سنه الاسلحه
الهجوميه في المستقبل القريب
[موسيقى]
قاعده قاعده
تطوير الثالوث النووي والحفاظ على
استعداده القتالي لان الدرع النووي كان
ولا يزال الضامن الرئيسي لسياده البلاد
وسلامه اراضيها سنعمل ايضا على زياده
القدرات القتاليه للقوات الجويه ومن بينها
عمل المقاتلات والقاذفات في المناطق التي
تعمل فيها انظمه الدفاع الجوي الحديثه
وكذلك تحسين الطائرات بدون طيار